[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bakou pour tout le monde les gens
dimanche soir fin de la journée jolie
promenade en trial et puis boum patapon
craque
ak c'est la guibole je vous tiens au
courant
[Musique]
d
ouais
m
[Applaudissements]
mais quels animaux suis-je chaud je
préfère le show
la famille la famille la famille weston
non aussi je vous ai ma place je préfère
la nuit
enfin le change pendant ces jeux pour
chanter non plus mais quand même
amouroux carrière
espère en confiance la confiance
qu'est-ce que je suis une panthère noire
sa cause du masque donc de raciste
ah
on regarde toi
ça y est c'est officiel
hier j'ai commandé à manger et le
coursier est arrivé et il a eu peur de
pépettes
de ça
[Rires]
mais à quoi
bon non quelle revanche